[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to if you
were to tell me back in 1987 that
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles was still
gonna be around thirty years later after
it first came on TV six year old me goes
yeah 36 year old Niko's what the hell is
kind of wrong with us it's weird to
think of all the comic-book characters
that could have the lasting power of
Batman with tons of different
incarnations over the years Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles would be one of the
major ones
even though I friggin adore and
everything turtle related growing up it
is odd to think that a clear product of
the late 80s and early 90s would lend
itself to so many reboots and spin-offs
many of them still very popular well I
can't say I have actively watched them
all I can say I kept taking a peep once
in a while to see what they were up to
kind of like checking in on an old
childhood friend who has many ups and
downs over the years Nickelodeon after
wrapping up a pretty popular run with
their last take of the series as we
voted the idea again with rise of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles because
everyone needs to be rising now for some
reason health they really want to make
this modern they call it the sleeping in
past noon because hell with your is
the goddamn weekend of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles fans have been
buzzing about their new design new style
and all around new field
well the turtles have certainly looked
and acted different in the past there
was a definite spin on this version that
seemed very unique compared to the
others Nickelodeon was so confident in
this new version that like Disney do
with the ducktales reboot they released
the first episode on YouTube and late
July
despite the show premiering
mid-september we lit win turtle fans
over can it suck in the newcomers does
anyone see YouTube videos they subscribe
to it they didn't press that goddamn
bell the answer to all of these is
pointlessly complicated yet somehow
simplistically dumb and we're gonna look
it over today let's take a look at rise
of the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
first let's examine the intro
it's pretty good amazing like
Thundercats x-men even original Ninja
Turtles amazing this whole opening is
done in one shot with no cuts and the
animation matches the incredible angles
and energy throughout the whole thing
it's a freaking rush this is one of
those intros you can watch over and over
and slow down to see what you missed
look there's that naked lady from the
rescuers only the other versions though
the song explains very little about who
the turtles are and even leaves out
their origin get used to that as you'll
see the episode starts off by explaining
how the two from UHF put it no really
watch two guys in gym clothes with dog
pouches and brows that ate their eyes
are chasing after a pika gizmo American
dragon that can teleport away oh yes it
gets stranger we randomly cut to
presumably a crime boss looking at the
briefcase from pulp fiction here we have
we see our heroes in a half-shell watch
this shady deal as they set up a
crackling hook cling on to the wire
swing right past the mob boss and
cannonball into a pool and if you're
thinking like I was how funny it would
be if we never see that crime boss again
we never see that crime boss again well
that is funny but what quickly the tone
of the show starts to reveal itself as
we look at the turtles designs and how
they act it looks like they kept some of
the additions from the bay produced Oh
as we see things like Donatella's tech
gear even down to a shell being half
robotic Michelangelo having more of the
silly goof off look at Raphael looking
roughened getting his name removed from
the Guinness ports records what kind of
shell roids is he taking I mean I like
the idea of the turtles being different
sizes but all of them are the exact same
except for him he literally picks up
Michelangelo with one hand and throws
him at one point did he also steal a
tooth from Leatherhead or is that just
open soda easier he's looking like clay
croc we also get the one constant change
in every turtle property April if you
step to my friends for step into you for
step 7 to me you have two steps
me pick changer so much in this
franchise Lando Calrissian is
complaining about her to Darth Vader
life altered April again pray I do not
alter her further this franchise is
getting wheeler all the time books are
fine as long as it matches the
personality trait like Michelangelo you
must be this rat to ride that ride the
party dude Leonardo oh yeah the party
dude Raphael the party dude and
Donatello the machine guy note also a
party do based on our velocity and entry
angle I concur Brad
well that's incredibly odd at least
April is there to act as a party dude
okay I'll admit it's not like the
turtles were the most fleshed out of
characters but in terms of their
personality you could still tell them
apart despite them looking identical
except for their mask colors you still
knew who would say what in a situation
for example who's this why don't we just
find these ninja thieves for and perhaps
she could help us find a cure for
splinters condition that's the ground of
responsibility of Leonardo who is this
bingo yeah we're dealing with a real
mine here
that's the wisecracking cynicism of
Raphael who's this rock dudes it's a
place where we can get some beats
that's the totally baked dim-witted
charm of Michelangelo now let's try it
with the other turtles who's this
teriyaki shakedown always gets me so
jazzed well that sounds like the
goofiness of Michelangelo up nope it's
not Nutella how about this what I can't
make a joke in the middle of the
craziest thing ever that's how I cope
well that also sounds like the goofiness
of Michelangelo oh it's Leonardo how
about this let's go Bungie dunk on the
hoops at Rucker Park well I'm just gonna
go against the grain and say that's
Raphael oh that's Michelangelo see a
problem don't get me wrong the voice
acting is good and they have great
delivery I can tell them apart just by
the vocals but in terms of the
personality there's little to no
difference some have even said that they
switched the leadership roles of having
Raph as the leader instead of Leo
but after seen forth these episodes I
couldn't
the leader is because they're all
exactly alike if you're wondering why
they're not going to their backstory
series villains or honestly any
character it's because this show is
taking a very similar route as Teen
Titans go the focus is more on jokes and
silliness rather than consistent
storytelling and yes I know how
ridiculous it sounds to demand
consistent storytelling from something
called Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles but
that was always kind of part of their
charm even though it was dumb it was
still an action series - and you can't
be that into the action if you're not
that into the story or characters Teen
Titans go has a very similar problem but
don't worry we'll get into that in a few
weeks for this however there's a great
irony that the action is harder to get
invested in because honestly it's some
of the best action the show is have ever
had watch to see what I'm talking about
as we get back to the story with April
and the turtles coming across pac-man's
furry here the two henchmen turned into
bug aliens riding their dogs as Steve's
and the action just kind of starts
without knowing what these two guys
personalities are look at them don't you
want to know more about these two
weirdos it not only would make the
comedy funny you're seeing their unique
personas work off of the Turtles but
we'd be more invested in the fight
itself
can you imagine fighting bebop and
rocksteady without establishing them at
all or the shredder or Krang or any
number of mutants that they fight over
the shows it was silly but it was fun
because we knew these guys so well and
so quickly even the most throwaway
villains had a distinct personality
always attached to them here it's bad
guys with no personality versus five
characters with only one personality
therefore it's not nearly as funny but
with that said it's kind of funny
there are some good one liners and
deliveries throughout the fights ones
that get a really hard laugh we thought
without your fake nerd voices I was
actually my real voice but you better
get intimidated what's wrong with my
voice
so you guys from Jersey these are good
jokes but they're not personality based
any one of those characters could say
those lines and get a laugh but again
the animation is crazy amazing and those
jokes do get legitimate laughs like I
love this random pizza boy who just
falls into an evil portal mid-fight did
you know April gets sucked in too along
with Wolverines build-a-bear and the
turtles have to figure out a way to
follow them hey April are your bits on
the other side of the wall well it feels
making Fox probably but Oh Oh bye bitch
you meant oh god sorry I thought you're
talking about hey I think this is a good
spot for a commercial
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're introduced to Master Splinter
who is the Tasmanian devil who also
calls his adopted sons by their colors
like what parents of kids who like ninja
turtles do and I thought purple was the
funny one
I'm just hoping he's playfully joking
around the same way I row or Yoda does
and he reveals days actually very wise
someday you would be great ninjas is
something I would say if I were a liar
nope he's kind of an asshole it can be
heroes like you Jitsu at least ray man
if he was kidnapped like in the movies
I'd be more than happy to bring down the
rat poison hey I've seen this before in
splinters
do not touch cabinet we gotta get
splinter out of the room I don't even
get it why let me just say they need the
device to save April and what do we say
if he asks why we want it that we needed
to go after our best friend who
disappeared into a wall yeah yeah Leo
steals it though when splinters asleep
and they use it to get to dimension in
over here hey bro I find April they hug
and then they merely just talk about
where they are we're in a mystic hidden
city it's the relationships that's the
heart of the show it turns out they're
under New York where a villain named
brenger Aksum plans to turn people into
mutants using the ooze and mosquitoes
they happen to find magic weapons
exactly like theirs except I'm sure
they'll cost more at the toy store and
they tell Baron to give back their
Simpson Momo stop creating imitation
crab
so how progressive is this version once
again they have a fight sequence and
well it's friggin amazing I can't
believe how good this animation is it's
like qulet kill fighting against the
turtle toy boxes it's beautiful to look
at accidentally impressive we talked
about two words that sum up this show
perfectly we don't spend enough quality
time again oh please not now my okay you
know there's gonna be enough slash out
of you guys you don't need to fuel the
fire drag sense machine falls apart just
drawing ish him future episodes and the
muffin minion teleports everyone out
making you wonder why he didn't just
teleport out before oh my god am i
applying logic to this show characters
don't mean just name your pet you
sure we're good through all that mayhem
hey man
oh and yourselves I guess you don't
think some like ninja mutant turtle
teens or I don't know maybe the lucky
brainstorming I mean think about the
European market hero might be better
than ninja but oh no a bunch of the
mosquitos get out and then it's over 22
minutes I'll just get them next time and
by next time I mean not in the next four
episodes
yeah the following episodes never
addressed this again focusing a more
wacky comedy than continuing plot so
this one just ends with the voice actor
asking us to give our thoughts alright
better like asking Gollum it's a pity
mounds ring some things you just don't
down since the other episodes are on
Nickelodeon site I won't go into too
much detail about them as I'm sure
they're building up for the September
premiere but I will say they're roughly
the same thing
the times are cut in half to 11 minutes
there's usually some problem or foe that
they have to overcome and they use
action and or jokes to overcome it like
I said there's no one main villain or
much of a continuing story or even
newah t mutants for example just seem to
exist in this world one owns a puppy
farm while another owns a junkyard
it isn't very clear how this world works
but again I think that's kind of the
point it'll be interesting to see if
they want to take this the same
direction as Adventure Time or Steven
universe where there's silly nonsense
mixed in with slow building drama if
that's the idea though there is no sign
of it yet and I kind of argue there
shouldn't be even in there Goofy's
episode the characters are very well
defined in those shows
so we've relate to them very easily and
know what they're going through even
when the tough stuff happens but like I
said before everyone in rise of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is exactly
the same character the only difference
it's a slight addition of some cliches
like Raph might say a tough stereotype
Don might say a geeky stereotype April
might say a sassy stereotype and
splinter might say an old stereotype so
the best way I can describe this show is
enjoyably frustrating there is a lot to
be impressed by some of it the most
impressive in any car nation of the
Ninja Turtles the action amazing the
designs colorful and unique the comedy
sometimes awkward but other times hugely
hilarious if they want to go for just
zany jokes like Ren & Stimpy or
spongebob I'm open to that but if they
want to add an action angle as well as
make memorable characters there has to
be a better understanding of who's being
portrayed and the environment they're
being portrayed in shows like gravity
falls or star versus the forces of evil
are silly but Mabel is going to be a
different kind of silly than grunkle
Stan Star is gonna have a different kind
of energy than Marko that's why we like
them and that's why we're with them both
through so much goofiness and so much
drama
but these characters have little variety
the best example I can think of of how
well this can work is in the Simpsons
the family has something mr. burns wants
and March says that they can get a
decent price for it and then make him
double it everyone once it are shocked
as she says why can't I be greedy once
in a while that only works because it's
Marge because you know her character
that would've worked if Bart said it or
Homer said it or
Olsen said it or Barney said it it has
to be the unique character they designed
for only her if this show wants to last
and stand out it has to have characters
as definable as these characters but
truth be told I think it can there are
some good lasts some fun ideas and some
incredible animation and I think it
should all be utilized as best as
possible well it has a clunky start it's
a stone with promise but their promises
that could ironically use a little more
limitation in some areas and a little
more expansion in others given the right
tuning this could be a very fun and
unique show I don't know what's next for
the Ninja Turtles whether this has a
long future or a short future ahead of
it but I hope it plays to its strengths
sharp incest all edges and turns out the
show worthy of the surprisingly
long-lasting Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
Island astounds our critic I remember it
so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey April are your bits on the other
side of the wall
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
Environmental Working Group the
environmental working groups mission is
to empower people to live healthier
lives in a healthier environment with
breakthrough research and education they
drive consumer choice and civic action
they are a nonprofit nonpartisan
organization dedicated to protecting
human health and the environment they
work for you finding out what's in your
tap water your shampoo what's lurking in
the cleaners underneath your sink
what pesticides are on your food and so
much more they also have an A rating on
charity watch which is a clear sign
they're top of their game for more than
two decades they set out to empower
everyone about how to get to know your
environment and protect your health
their website and their YouTube channel
has so much information about the simple
steps you can take to protect yourself
and others from the dangers of so many
things in our everyday lives
pollution littering chemicals this stuff
is everywhere and these folks show you
why what and how to help they take so
many big steps to show you the little
steps that you can take click on the
link and see how even the tiniest of
changes can make the biggest of
differences
you